renee is with us in chicago good
afternoon renee how can dr john and i
help
hi guys um first of all thanks so much
for letting me be on your show
yeah um but i had a question regarding
just student loans in general so
um a little background i i'm starting a
new job next week
um and i'm going to make about 65 000
a year so um not you know it's good
a good first start for my first job
outside of school i just graduated from
grad school
i'm 23 years old and i also have
about 42 thousand dollars in federal
student loan debt
so i guess my question is about the best
plan
um the best way possible to pay this off
as soon as possible
um but also like if there's also a
chance to do that while also taking care
of myself like
you know still eating out like you know
every once in a while at a nice place or
like buying myself
like nice things every once in a while
you know
so i was just wondering if there's a way
to budget that
renee um yes no you don't have any
you don't have any time you don't have
any resources to be buying yourself nice
things okay
right now you're going to stay with the
college mindset you are broke
you did nice things to yourself for the
last six years okay
but i don't want to be broke hey listen
listen hey that's a problem
for 18 year old renee yes
this is 23 year old renee is paying the
piper all right renee
yeah so outside of these student loans
do you have any other debt
no i don't fortunately don't um
undergrad i didn't have that
luckily um and i actually currently so i
currently still live with my parents
okay
and i do plan on moving to
the city soon which i yeah
expensive city yeah that's where the job
is
you can't you can't live outside of the
city and drive into the city
well my plan was to stay at home until i
have to go back to work because
you know because of covet everyone's
working from home now so
i'm not going to move now if i don't
have to but when
we do plan on going back then i do plan
on going
but the rent there is about
hundred 1200 a month um so it's it's
what how old are you twenty-three
twenty-three
what's your what's your career what
would you go to grad school for
um so i'm doing uh like market research
and consulting
okay all right check this out yeah check
this out
oh sorry what was that i said check this
out okay you're not gonna like that
you got a pen and paper near you get a
pen and paper uh
yeah okay cool or just just yeah yeah
because i'm about to give you some stuff
you need to do
okay here's number one
just write down no okay
no you you don't have time to buy
yourself nice things and
no you don't have time to be going on
nice vacations no you don't have
time to be going out with your friends
every other weekend no the answer is no
i want you to put that up in your mirror
every single day and look at the word
no okay number two
um is um
i think right now at 23 years old
staying home i'm okay with that
but at 23 also at the same time i want
you to have a solid plan
of how are you going to get outside of
your parents house i don't want you to
be there until you're 30. i don't want
you to stay there until you're 27.
um i'm gonna say give yourself at least
a good year at home
she's gotta move as soon as covet comes
as soon as you're as soon as you go back
to
to work in house you gotta get out right
yeah you gotta go she said
she said that that's her yeah her
requirement i'll get you i'm just saying
if things prolong i'm saying she needs
to have an injury
you need to have an end date of when
you're going to leave um and then here's
the thing
i'm not moving to the city renee i get
it you're young you want to be closer to
the city get closer to your job
but twelve hundred dollars a month right
now on rent when you can probably live
on the outskirts of the city
and drive something nice and live in
something maybe around 800
900 a month would be a better option
because right now
you need to attack this 42 thousand
dollars of student loan debt and here's
the thing
you're making great money so if you get
on a strict
budget if you can figure out how to get
your living expenses
very low i mean very low
you should be able to throw at least
25 000 uh towards this 42 thousand
dollars this year
you should be able to be out of debt by
next year
and i'm talking like you're you're
getting this job you're going to be
driving for uber
you're going to be trying to figure out
something you can do on the side to
generate another 20 000
because if you really get gazelle
intense renee you can honestly be debt
free within the next
year 12 months 12 to 14 months you could
be debt-free because right now you don't
have any expenses
so right now if you're staying at home
man i'm throwing everything towards debt
i'm gonna throw my mom and dead a couple
hundred dollars for food electricity
and water bills but outside of that man
i'm throwing everything at this 42
thousand dollars so that way when you do
leave your home
you are debt free and you're still gonna
live in the outskirts because you need
to set aside that three to six months of
expenses
and listen renee i promise anthony and i
get it
you went to grad school you're smart
you're fancy you're 23.
yeah you have all you man you're going
to go to the big city
and you're going to live it out exactly
but listen
see you feel like you've arrived you
feel like you're 100 years old
you walk a little bit taller it's going
to be good what i'm telling you is this
on your 25th birthday if you are
debt-free
not if she will be yeah i like that you
will be debt for your 25th birthday
you're going to realize that at the age
of 25
you aren't very old you're going to
realize that you have your entire life
ahead of you to do whatever
you want to do because 23
year old renee sucked it up and got it
done
now listen you're looking at a guy right
now who with a
young child me and my wife moved into
a dorm at a college so we wouldn't have
expenses
anthony lived in his car we have done
some extreme things
we've done some crazy people my friends
our friends have been like what are you
doing
you know what we're doing we're changing
everything because this game
isn't going to play and i'll tell you
this at 25
you're not going to remember those meals
you blew that money on at 23. you're not
going to remember
that party on top of that party on top
of that party you're not i'm telling you
you're not going to remember it
what you are going to love doing is
waking up on your 25th birthday
having no payments and thinking i think
i was going to move to
yeah fill in the blank because you can
so renee hold on hold on the line i'ma
have madison give you a copy of destroy
your uh student loans
um it's a quick read that i read i want
you to stay online and get that
and just remember the caliber of your
future will be determined by the choices
you
made today make the right one by
listening to dr john and i alright
this is the ramsay show